[Musique]
les gens qui me liront les hôtels de la
ville
si tous kankan est astucieux
[Musique]
c'est le plus sérieux à jouer il suffit
de vouloir revenir à un ami
bonjour bonjour peut encore une petite
ou du bonjour bonjour titoune yeux rue
et ça va bien ça va et toi mm bonjour
j'ai mûri à tous les amis parce que ils
s'intéressent beaucoup à toutes les
expériences à narrer spa ti tout à tout
prévoir et bien alors aujourd'hui
oui nous avons préparé une expérience
assez facile à réaliser
je vais t'expliquer seulement elle et
elle est très longue
alors je vous montrerai le départ de
l'expérience et puis vous la ferez chez
vous il vous faudra avoir de la patience
car c'est assez long et oui alors voilà
comment les choses se passent une
bouteille tout simple un bouchon et
alors là il faut que nous regardions
gros plans parce que nous avons planté à
l'intérieur du bouchon une c'est une
épingle ça commence à une aiguille plus
exactement c'est une aiguille et vous
alors l'aiguillé qui est ici on a bien
pris soin de mettre la pointe en l'air
maintenant nous allons réaliser un de
ces extraordinaires équilibre que nous
avons déjà fait plusieurs fois avec vous
c'est un équilibre étonnant qu'on ne
réussit pas toujours forme petit peu de
patience
et puis ensuite je vous expliquerai ce
qu'on fera alors regardez la bombe à
bord il n'y a pas de danger
non non il n'y a pas de danger en
principe devait d'abord réaliser
l'équilibré
attention c'est un peu délicat voilà à
ça c'est la première partie de l'aide
est chaud mais vous avez déjà fait ce
genre d'exercice il ya un bouchon de
canif
on a fait l'équilibré le furent aussi
peut-être avec des fourchettes ou des
choses changent parfois que ça 10 à un
certain poids pour que ça marche
bon vu thi thu oui mais ce n'est pas
fini à temps car si vous avez la
patience d'attendre assez longtemps
peut-être une heure et bien si vous
faites tourner en soufflant comme ceux
ci par exemple et vous si vous faites
tourner cet engin sa tombe mais je le
remets vous arriverez d'une façon
étonnante à creuser un véritable trou
dans la vis et oui vous creusez un trou
vous arrivera trop
ce père c'est la vis car la pointe de
l'aiguillon est en acier extrêmement dur
alors que la vis est plutôt molle enfin
beaucoup moins dur que l'aiguillé et au
bout d'une heure lorsque vous aurez la
patience de faire tourner cet engin
autour de l'église vous aurait
transpercé votre fils il faut du temps
mais c'est formidable
outre fabrice y est exposé et exaltant
fait de l'exaltante exaltant ok alors tu
as vu regarde derrière nous il y avait
des scènes des petits amis là oui tu
vois là nous avons les desseins de ceux
qui nous ont envoyé des dons est
formidable mais n'en sélectionner son
body dont le mot à mot là j'y vais tout
de suite dans le mot amour et mes
enfants
le modem se situe pouvait en trouver
quelques mots à maux et ce sont des
petits cartons que vous allez voir
lesquels représentent par leurs desseins
des syllabes des morceaux de mot vous
essayer de reconstituer un mot complet à
partir de ce que vous allez voir est ce
que vous êtes prêts oui dans ma loge
nous allons nous allons le faire ce pas
je vais commencer et tout quand tu vas
me dire au fur et à mesure de la sortie
des cartons ce qu'il représente alors
j'en prends 5 3 4 et 5
voilà bon alors ça je pense que c'est
assez si certains jugent nous sommes
d'accord sur ça ça c'est une pile
oui bien j'ai c'est une pique une pile
ceci à tous tourte au crédit et ça a un
sens
un cerf à sachant voit dans les bois
toutefois quand je vois le dit jah c'est
vrai tu envoies oui son goal esri un
jour sur ces bois il m'a jeté à la porte
ça c'est des yeux oui sont des yeux 8c
des yeux voilà alors nous allons essayer
de faire un mot avec tout cela avec ses
skis on devrais voir quelque chose est
normalement vos barrières la vitesse
qu'il y avait encore trouver quoi bien
du sang le sert d'abri soussan l'essai
we put jamais le 16 tu sors les yeux ça
lui sert sérieux sérieux il fera oui
c'est bien joué ça évidemment fait valve
a pas bravo les sérieux hiram au sérieux
et c'est rien ça c'est formidable
sérieux trouver un nom mais j'ai pas
trouvé c'est sérieux ça c'est bien joué
sérieux en fait de sortir d'autres des
cartons en oui je crois sur les bras les
lanceurs d'eau d'autres cartons alors ça
se sent bah oui apparemment
et puis alors ça ça je vois pas ce que
c'est un quai à wisekey est un quai de
gare ou de métro ça alors attends
attends
oui oui c'est souvent dans la couche à
attention attention je crois que j'ai
trouvé à lille a pris langue il est joli
ce mot un regarde tout cas encore oui si
vous me suis regardé bien oui je prends
la toux tout et tout oui je prends le
nid tournis tournis retourné je n'ai pas
fini tournissan non ton ni pile nyon
tourniquets du tourniquet tourniquet
voit bien ça alors tourniquet quand je
fais une barre de séparation mais
j'écris ça j'aurais eu le temps je leur
ai trouvé
ah oui bon c'est long mais si j'ai été
pris un petit peu de surprises tu crois
par espère anne lise là il est fort fort
tour ni voilà il passait bien sa tournée
je dois dire que tu es très fort c'est
toi qui dois choisir là je vais choisir
la lettre k vous
avait envoyé de fort jolies lettres vous
pouvez continuer à le faire d'ailleurs
et vous nous avez envoyé des dessins
absolument y pas tant je suis autant
plus admiratif que je vous rappelle moi
je ne sais pas dessiner je suis nulle
absolument nulle et là vraiment pour
elle on pourra le mettre le prochain
dans notre galerie là oui oui absolument
un dessin était de jean-luc c'est
vraiment un beau dessin ébouriffant oui
je vous sais mais bien oui évidemment
l'orthographe fait un peu proche de
celle de pouce moussu c'est-à-dire il ya
quelques fautes mais ce n'est pas grave
le dessin est tellement beau je crois
qu'on peut lui pardonner
ah oui c'est même peut-être nous aider à
pousser jean luc qui a 8 ans va recevoir
le disque des quatre amis à oui on a
bien mérité
ah oui avec nous à le disque des quatre
familles qui vivent les trous et bien
sûr si vous avez envie de chanter cette
chanson bon message est bon dit oui
c'est à nous maintenant ah oui alors si
alors tu vas au tableau en civil alors
tu vas au tableau j'espère qu'on a bien
travaillé et qu'elle vient travailler en
bâche et seguer tu sais jamais si c'est
difficile l'orthographe d'un mot en
huile être avons quand même oui mais a
quand même eu huit lettres on commence
par quelle lettre la première lettre 7h
à bord h
voilà voilà à l'actif entre 1 2 3 4 5 6
et et la dernière un t1 t1 t comme
théodore bien voilà alors puisque tu es
très gourmand en ce moment je suppose
que que ça se mange encore oui ça se
mange épicier drôlement bon au fond et
ça commence par anne h
ou alors c'est non de leur part fait la
même chose non pas un légume
non non non non c'est pas pendant la
dernière fou maintenant c'est pas comme
la dernière phase est pas un légume
pains légumes ça alors c'est de la
viande non c'est pas de la viande
c'est un fruit c'est un cd un fruit qui
est un fruit de fruits rouges rouges
oui enfin il est rose et il est pas
spécialement rouge n'aura pas
spécialement ronde il a une belle
couleur oui il est très juteux n'est
très bon attend-on mans une autre lettre
dans une autre lettre alors la troisième
oui c'est un b
un bébé oui là là ça va être facile pour
toi c'est c'est joe louis jaune rose ai
été très bon ça y est oui c'est à cause
de la dernière fois mais c'est pas
possible tu penses aux abricots un abric
ah oui un abricot voilà avec un h la wii
comme haricots a bien sûr mais mon
pauvre pouces moussu enfin voyons
comment abricots il n'y a pas de hache à
brigade97kat pas de changer pour ce pari
qu il fallait 1 h alors abricots quand
même non abricot sans arrêt roe bros
brawl moi je savais pas que ça va mal ça
parce que je peux te dire c'est que pour
les abricots
il faut beaucoup de soleil oui bombardé
de belles couleurs il faut beaucoup de
soleil non c'est pour ça qu'on en trouve
surtout dans le midi de la france
oui ça je ne t'apprends rien que c'est
que tu le savais qu'un puissant rebond
est bien alors si nous allons voir
maintenant si nous allions voir belle
belle oui tu aimes bien belle belle oui
moi j'adore pas où l'on va voir belle et
on va voir belbel tous les toits fabrice
vial jouer avec moi c'est facile la
musique tube est à saluer nous allons
continuer à voir des instruments de
musique bel ben dhia civ j'adore ça ça
tombe bien
alice a déjà prouvé que tu étais capable
de reconnaître justement un instrument
de musique en écoutant rien que le son
de cet instrument
oui je crois que je peux en retrouver
beaucoup comme ça il aurait alors
pourrais tu nous dire quel est
l'instrument que je vais te faire
entendre
vaz a tant que j'appuie sur la bonne
touche voilà
[Musique]
ça
c'est grave a wish très grave
un instrument à corde ça un gros
instrument à gorge
[Musique]
ça montre quand même ça monte et ça
descend
[Musique]
mais c'est plutôt un instrument qui a
des notes très grave
c'est une contrebasse exact mais voilà
c'est encore un instrument à cordes
je crois que nous avons une contrebasse
pas très loin mais je vais la chercher
car tu n'as pas eu la force de la portée
mais qui va voir gvt mais puisque ses
ténors ont recours est ce qu'on dira un
gros éléphant à comprendre cette
contrebasse ici là c'est très difficile
et très loose et d'ailleurs on ne peut
pas se promener comme ça dans la rue
avait au non paiement bien évidemment ce
n'est pas comme le violon vous imaginez
qu'on ne peut pas le mettre sous le
menton pour jouer avec un archet une
force non sûr c'est un gros instrument
alors tu sais belles belles que cet
instrument on l'utilisent dans la
musique classique avec un archet alors
on est en général dans un orchestre
symphonique
ah si je crois sur anne assez hauts
tabourets et on joue avec un archet 6 à
2 cet instrument d'ailleurs tu vas tu va
l'entendre
ça peut évoquer par exemple un gros
éléphant comme dans le carnaval des
animaux y coûte
oui
[Musique]
ce sont les éléphants qui marque
ah oui
ton
[Musique]
voilà alors pour faire les notes bas
vous utilisez bien entendu la main
gauche et vous pincer les corps vous
appuyez sur les cordes pour réduire la
longueur des cordes et faire des notes
mais n'y a pas que la musique classique
qui utilisent la contrebasse dans le
jazz par exemple on utilise la
contrebasse sans archet on joue avec les
doigts ça s'appelle pizzicato qu'est ce
que tu fais toi hein ne bouge pas hein
parce que tu l as one seat en jeu ce
soir
alors dans le jazz on joue debout et on
pince pour faire les notes mais c'est
infernal
moi ça fait huit équipes ça fait du
rythme voilà un rouge comme ça qu'on
fait les notes comme ça moi je ne sais
pas jouer mais ça ressemble à ça eh bien
je ne fais pas mal aux doigts ça fait
très très mal
on doit avoir de l'accord et il faut il
quand on joue beaucoup on a de la corne
au doigt oui c'est vrai parce que c'est
un instrument très difficile aussi il
est très beau et rage c'est magnifique
il ressemble à un groupe hyper sexy un
petit peu la voix la salle aragon moi
c'est tout doux
voilà ce que j'ai déjà mal aux doigts
fabrice oui bien vu que nous maintenant
oui je vais venir maintenant pour
chanter avec fruits alors si répose et
de ne pas faire de mal à la contrebasse
voilà bon ça arrive tu te rappelles un
petit peu de notre chanson mais bien
encore de là nous partons maintenant
dans du classique le carnaval des
animaux tout ça mais aussi les quatre
amis et quatre amis sont déjà bons
copains
rami lille tard diront qu'ils secrète de
la vie je chope se déchausse les comme
juni batoumi noir il faudra faire
attention les gars de sa vie quand ils
ont réussi mais y'a qu'ça mi temps de
retard is he may be
oui
moi
[Musique]
j'invite à jouer aujourd'hui et c'est
fini a dit vouloir devenir amis
[Musique]